I'm gonna try to write 29:37 as a
decimal so this is the exact same thing
as 29 29 divided by divided by 37 and
this is clearly going to be less than 1
29 is less than 37 and it's going to
involve some decimals here so let me
just put the decimals in place right
here so we are ready to use them so let
me throw some zeros some zeros as many
zeros as we might need we might need
even more than that but let's see what
we can do so 37 definitely doesn't go
into 2 it goes into 2 0 times 37 goes
into 29 is 0 times
so 20 30 seven goes into 290 well it'll
go into 290 and let's see I would
estimate that it goes see 8 times 37
would be 240 plus 56 which is too big
who's gonna be 7 so let's do 7 times 7
times so we have our decimal out here we
could throw a zero out there if we want
7 times 37 well 7 times 7 is 49 plus 7
times 30 which is 210 210 plus 49 is 259
so it's 259 and we can subtract that and
we are left with 290 - 259 which is
going to be once it's gonna be 10 it's
going to be an 8 it's going to be 31 and
now we can bring down the next zero 37
goes in to 310 see that looks like it'll
be 8 times so 8 times 8 times 7 is 56 8
times 3 is 24 plus 5 is 29 so 296 it
worked out
310 - 296 well that's going to be 14 now
we bring down another 0 let's bring down
a 0 and blue bring down another 0 37
goes into 140 let's see does it go 4
times that would be 120 + 28 no that's
too large gonna go 3 times
3 times 7 is 21 3 times 3 is 9 plus 2 is
11 111 you subtract and you are left
with 29 this is a fairly tedious problem
let's see where it goes so now let's
bring down bringing out another 0 oh we
got the 290 again 37 goes in to 290 well
we know this we've seen this drill
before 37 goes into 297 times let me do
in that same color as the other 7 it
goes
7 times 7 times 37 we've already figured
it out is 259 you subtract you're gonna
get 31
you're gonna bring down another zero and
you you see this whole show over again
37 goes in to 310 we already figured
that out it goes 8 times 8 times 37 was
296 296 you subtract you get 14 you
bring down another zero so you bring
down so we already brought this zero
down we're gonna read another zero let
me make it clear which the zeroes I'm
bringing down so this is this one right
over here and we're about to bring down
another or we just brought down another
zero so that's this zero right over here
37 goes into one forty we've already
done it three times three times and so
we see this pattern repeating its 0.783
seven eight three it's going to keep
going seven eight three 73 73 on and on
and on forever so we can write this as
we can say this is the same thing as
zero point seven I'll do the same colors
seven eight three and to show that we
keep repeating not just the three we
keep repeating the seven eight three we
put this line over all three right over
here so this literally means that we
repeat seven eight three 73 73 over and
over and over and over again